quando você acha que tem estilo
bom vamos ter consciência então do que é
isso steel e alguns de vós acha que não
tem e por vezes achamos que nem
precisamos deu tentaram abordar o tema
do steel é de uma forma que nos ajuda
tanto a quem está à procura que sabe o
primeiro emprego e acha que existe um
pouco faz falta em termos do que
aprendeu academicamente nos outros que
já cá andamos há uns anos a fazer a vida
e mesmo os que estão longe faz falta
nenhuma
tem um conceito em 13 em uma arte está
sustentada por três colunas que eu diria
que são originalidade e autenticidade ea
credibilidade e como é que nós
conseguimos apontar estes três valores
ao nosso estilo
quem é que vocês acham que tem mais tio
nesta fotografia é mesmo uma criança de
oito anos que ela está muito prazer sou
eu e em 1968 era então acho que tem
propriedade para poder abordar o tema
neste facto ao lado do meu pai e do
senhor foi até o meu pai é um homem
distinto olha o lado direito
comecei a trabalhar estilo muito cedo
dentro de mim
vamos abordar então isto com quem mais
seria dada
alguém consegue pôr em causa a questão
podem colocar a vocês próprios que é se
eu vou fazer uma entrevista do primeiro
emprego ou segundo
vou vender a minha imagem alguém para
que é que eu preciso
se eu sou um académico tão bom se eu
tenho tanto conhecimento
quer contratar pra que eu preciso hostil
eu vou tentar dar um exemplo os mais
recentes porque assim a memória curta é
capaz de nos ajudar mais a todos a
compreender um visto há muito pouco
tempo atrás alguém apareceu com uma
autêntica obra dar colocar luz no
compêndio como é que se faz uma canção
como é que juntamos alquimia da harmonia
da moradia da letra da expressão numa
canção num compêndio de música como é
que se constrói uma canção e alguém
apareceu e se apresentou ao mundo e não
só a europa
como escrevi uma canção não tem um erro
de um lado a outro mas na primeira vez
que somente apresentou essa canção eu
diria mesmo essa obra da arte em forma
de canção a opinião pública que ouviu as
redes sociais que os fazem da opinião
pública
na semana a seguir à primeira coisa que
conseguiram criticar foi hostil hostil
com que se apresentou vestindo o
maneirismo de luto izawa na
interpretação da sua atenção
querem dizer com pessoas criticaram a
linguagem verbal ou não verbal de
linguagem gestual criticaram a sua
linguagem não verbal ea sua linguagem
gestual sem olhar sequer para obra de
arte que o homem acabava de oferecer a
quem o ouvia todos nós lembramos de
salvador sobral
momentos mais tarde não conquista só
europa onde estava o concurso conquistou
o mundo
por que por que a obra era boa mas a
primeira coisa que nós olhamos quase
todos não foi para a obra que o fez em
conjunto com mais alguém olhar pro moto
como eu se apresentou pro moto como eu
falou então provavelmente o estilo faz
nos falta para podermos chegar alguém de
moda que precisamos mostrar a nossa obra
de arte
eu vou abordar o tema extremo e peço
desculpa às senhoras
vou abordar o tema esteve muito
concentrado naquilo que foi o estilo
masculino através dos tempos
algumas têm um pai do namorado eo alguém
que gosta e quem mais do que uma senhora
pra tomar conta do estilo mas por favor
não levem a mal eu penso que seria muito
mais facilmente identificável história
como eu em cima do trio excluindo que o
facto e eu não conseguia falar
seria quase impossível as ferramentas do
seu concorrente história trazer um pouco
do conhecimento já que estamos no meio
acadêmico
começamos a cumprir o nosso corpo por
necessidades climáticas ou porque
tínhamos muito frio e cobriremos temos
obtínhamos muito calor e qualquer
filhinha de para servir ao propósito
depender muito do sítio onde iríamos nós
até que um dia começamos a fiar afi área
de ser e fizemos sítio e então aquilo
que importamos miklósi brilhantes do tom
isto tá começar a falar por mim
se conseguir parar do vosso lado
esquerdo está um senador um homem que
aporta governação que aporta riqueza do
lado direito está exatamente o oposto um
homem que abordado ea humildade sendo o
monge ambos bastante credíveis se
apostarmos a credibilidade temos
bastante credíveis quem olha brews
acreditar no que estão fazendo
o direito de um sido provavelmente foi o
primeiro designer de moda porque
gravidade é que a gente vai fazer o quê
ir 15 até o chão e é grave nato faz um
design mais tarde
os uniformes militares são desenhados
por a performance hierarquia possamos
perfeitamente que é um soldado ambos vão
ter a mesma performance mas a hierarquia
também está presente e olhamos para o
centurião e um facto aparece com maior
credibilidade do que o seu lado para a
sua missão
então a roupa é uma ferramenta de
comunicação já não serão simplesmente a
proteção dos outros e do clima mas ela
está enviar uma mensagem pro neco é
campos aparece à vontade é muito
interessante porque hoje em dia uma das
peças que foi tão nossa e agora dirigida
aos homens
então nossa gestão porque é importante
para mim mas irá passar com certeza
absoluta sobre ficaram adquiridos temos
um grande terracota provavelmente foi o
primeiro é primeira é a imagem que temos
história daquilo que o adorno do pescoço
será o nosso em termos de identificação
pessoal
nenhum grupo tinha um lance igual está
colocada na parte mais alta do morro do
corpo fala por mim eu falo por mim
do lado direito está em um guerreiro
o reino é croata talvez daí é que nós
começamos a palavra gravata
o zagueiro croata é parece um filme de
tropas que em paris
as tropas croatas dos mercenários
croatas todos os réus tenham em sua
volta do pescoço
cada um deles confeccionava pelo mero ou
pela manhã pela namorada que seria um
tocão mais pra guerra lembra de mim
estou cá é único mas curiosamente essa
mensagem está conosco e agora vão
dirigir aos homens e vou introduzir aqui
algo que eu ia dizer há três maneiras de
adquirir uma gravata
esta peça em que está fora de moda
há três maneiras de adquirir uma gravata
uma delas é pela oferta de mais 30 da
mãe é sempre linda não essa é a pergunta
sempre bonita
é só começar a uma compra assistida que
alguém entrar na frente 56 gravatas para
jogar com algum conjunto terminar o fato
e o funcionário deverá atender vai dizer
como é que se encontra a escola costa
mais uma gravata não sentir assim da
mensagem emocional que ela tem
nós queremos uma gravata como se
tivéssemos a seduzir uma mulher bonita
curioso mas é mesmo assim que eu vou
passar na rua e posso olhar para o lado
e dizer linda gravata
eu vou entrar eu vou perguntar ao senhor
que está na loja mostra aquela gravata e
eu como um bom fiz isso não vai me dizer
temos animais mas ele não quer ver
aquela é uma relação à noite numa
relação a outras
eu quero ver aquela quer convidar aquela
gravata primeiro comigo pra casa com ela
só vai estar cortado e não são eles que
vamos entrar pra casa leva pra casa e no
outro dia vai com calma e todos nós
sabemos uma coisa é a única peça de
roupa que fazemos festas vez que
colocamos à prova da indy 300 de uma
festa
então é uma peça extremamente emocional
eu já não sou um rapaz novo tem gravadas
com trinta e tal anos hoje consigo andar
do hotel - as minhas gravatas
todas elas têm uma história e falam
comigo o simbolismo de gravatá a porta
então estes dois senhores autenticidade
e originalidade é fundamental quando nós
queremos mostrar o nosso estilo ser uns
autênticos e serão os originais após a
história da gravata vamos votar um
carrinho traz voltarmos atrás vamos ver
exatamente a mesma coisa que não evoluiu
ao longo dos séculos
continuamos a ter para os clientes mais
roupa mais adorno mais luxo mais cabelo
que interessa que haja muito mais e
então tanto o nosso rei o rei sol e
escritores como o nosso a questão balas
investem muitos órgãos anos caem
extremamente adornado lançar agora uma
próxima gestão
destes 3 contra o homem que aparece com
mais estilo
o fato que nós temos hoje o teu taer que
espera ver se tem hoje
a partir daí só me chama se jorge bobo
humano
estou meio ao fundador do movimento que
se chama organismo
nós jogamos por muitas publicações de
dândis alguém se ache um dândi aqui não
consigo falar com deus
hoje em dia aparecem muitas publicações
que aparecem os que o usuário assim como
eu mas mais compridas nos jogos com 11
gols para eles e nós somos uns dentes
movimento dá-lhe não nasceu agora
movimentando e chegou por volta de 1790
com que o senhor não estar a meio do
princípio as pessoas tinham como você
estão recordados como o marquês de
pombal e este senhor chegou ao fim e
atinge eu quero um casaco curto calças
o povo é que usava calça da nobreza
usava coloque online
quero calças eram umas botas do site
não quero nada do curado buscando
investir assim mas entretanto esta mãe
curtiu crê
hoje em dia na catedral os alfaiates é
uma rua sem onde há maior concentração
dos royalties do mundo chama sabe o
roubo chamou lagoa maior
está tudo tem uma estatura este senhor e
os alfabetos todos em 2d dizem é este
homem foi atualmente no frio estava
entre um movimento que através dos
tempos tem vários indivíduos que são
protagonistas óscar well dizer que moda
não saía tão fire fire muda de seis em
seis meses depois o nosso eduardo 8o que
conheceram o do ensaio e enfim trocou
realeza pelo amor da sua vida e quer um
homem que patenteava steel nomeadamente
eu tenho porém foi o evento junta juntos
coríntio estas três destas três figuras
que ali estão e que dizem que
sofisticação siervi de cinco anos em um
momento que os 11 anos pra mim talvez
seja essa arte circundante
será um evento não é ser magro nem
gordos têm a ver com massa e como a
terra e não tem a ver com mais nada
eu conheço o senhor assange generosa que
são muito grandes e homem generoso muito
mais que são muito prudentes
talvez em um lancia seja dress for the
oc
onde é que eu vou como é que um visto
eu tenho que me levantar de manhã a
receber o meu estado de alma que é
fundamental mas também por ser o dia que
eu vou ter e vamos ter o dia que eu vou
ter com quem eu gostaria de dizer que
sirva em ser pontual não é mais do que o
respeito do outro e vai tentar ser
envolvente e voltar alguns têm um e
assistiu é o nome de seis em seis meses
o segredo e eu consegui pegar nem
essência desse fenômeno de moda seja na
cura seja na forma e vou ficar esse
período e trago prometeu
se eu for absorver a moda todas em seis
meses
eu não passo de algo que anda a passar
coisas diferentes mas não me identifico
e gravata que hoje ele está substituída
por um lenço algo que tem que portar mim
porque quem trabalha ou que foram à
procura trabalho e mails institucionais
e eu diria escritórios de advogados
consultores que contratou um engenheiro
da ciência e da tecnologia são abstratos
em resolver a bem pouco tempo imaginação
e achei por lá acham que enfrenta um
fato cinzento e um fato azul na porta da
unidade
mas o que faz a diferença entre mim e os
outros em e gravata ou então não é algo
que eu diga eu tenho ativá-lo teu estou
estou eu sou eu
nós não somos iguais algo diferente
não é de agora pra china
este senhor foi ótimo mas estava uma
senhora vai continuar o trabalho deste
senhor chama de coco chanel
a senhora que faz o time é que adaptou o
fato do homem ao fato da senhora e foi
ainda conseguiu trazer impossível que
todos se lembram o engano já agora
quantos uma outra história é todos
conhecem o twitter é um tecido osgood
bonito mas muito resistente anúncio do
homem que andava pelos vossos pode
resistir à agressividade da estação com
o coxa não foi capaz de dar nesse título
de homem e transformá-lo em peças
lindíssimas de senhora e hoje todos nós
foi instruída chama-se twitter porque
alguém um dia ou anos recebeu vez das
referidas um fardo com um é se a que se
chamava do rio acompanhou chuva o senhor
leu mal e passou a escrever twitter é a
partir daqui nós estamos a investir o
que somos hoje e o tempo de fato que
atinge 35 ao exército vai pra cima está
em harmonia e de hockey chã onde eu vou
assim eu visto não cabe na cabeça de
ninguém que um consultor vai visitar um
agricultor de fato cinzento e gravata
eu só vai afastar dele com certeza
portanto é muito importante nós sabemos
onde vamos como é que nós vamos ter para
conseguir chegar ao outro que é o que
pretendemos é comunicar ao fim e ao cabo
o senhor samuel se iria criar e o vosso
estilo visual deixem seja une para vocês
mas que ainda assim os outros consigam
identificar não ingerem muito para que
os outros percam ganhar vamos falar uma
coisa eu estar proibido olhar só para
gravar daqui é muito grande e nem ovo
que nós estamos a dizer cuidado está a
nossa eu venci o meu famoso e obviamente
enorme colega raúl flora diz que fecha
neste lado nessa série a maior lembrança
ele nota boal prende e observados em
portugal se transformou em 2000
reparem que ambos ambos estão a apelar
ao interior você tem que descobrir o seu
tio da áfica qualquer coisa lá dentro
nem o seguram muito bem explicar mas vem
e buscar dentro de si criaram nós vamos
ter uma opção de compra é bom falar nos
connosco será que eu gosto que é que
estás por mim porque eu gosto de ver com
esta pessoa não o que quis dizer acerca
de mim eu quero comunicar aos outros é
que começamos a criar o nosso próprio
estilo
muitíssimo obrigado pelo vosso tempo
[Aplausos]